good morning believe nation I started
them making it series to try to learn
from people who've accomplished success
in a certain field learn from them get
their advice on how you can reach
success in that field as well and so we
had a lot of success with the first one
making it as a musician we're gonna
continue the series the pilot project
see if you guys still want this series
to continue this one is gonna be making
it as an actor as you watch it there's
something that somebody says that really
resonates with you as usual please leave
it in the comments below and put quotes
around that to other people can be
inspired as well when I was younger
everybody told me not to be an actor to
this day I say that to people who come
up to me and say I'm thinking of going
into acting what do you think I say
absolutely not it's a terrible idea
don't do it because that's what everyone
said to me and I think if you're gonna
make it in this business that is so full
of rejection and hardship you need to
believe in yourself despite what
everybody you love and trust tells you
and and it's a very personal journey and
so so that was really helpful I think
you know the advice to stay away from
this career was really helpful in my own
understanding that it was that important
that I pursue it I think the audition
process is no different than going for a
meeting as a cinematographer or if you
want to be in any of the of the
disciplines of this industry very often
the thing that actors tend to do is I
think they tend to focus on the wrong
thing so if I were to say to you what do
you think the purpose of an audition is
what was your answer be what's the
purpose of an audition
to live truthfully in the moment very
nice most people would say to get the
job all right now that is a very very
very dangerous place to start to want to
get the job now look let's face facts if
you get the job how great that's great
its icing on the cake it's fantastic but
I believe that if actors were better
willing to adopt a philosophy that it is
an opportunity to walk into a room and
to begin a relationship that may not pay
off with that particular job sometimes
actors are so nervous and they want that
job so much or they can't pay their rent
they gotta get down Jonathan hi well we
see that you know the director sees that
so the problem with that is that you're
not being yourself you can't be truthful
in the moment when your focus is on the
result instead of what on that day at
that moment is the beginning of a
process can I work with this actor the
directors thinking does this actor pay
attention do they listen and when I give
them direction do they actually change
anything do they take direction go that
way and if you can stand in a room and
say I may be raw I may be undeveloped I
may have no experience but I trust
myself enough and I believe in myself
enough on this day that I want to
introduce myself to this director cast a
director producer assistant and by the
way be really nice to the assistants
because no one behind that table is any
different than you everyone behind that
table is just as ambitious as you are
that director wants to be doing better
things that casting director wants to be
a director that assistant that assistant
wants to be the casting director
everybody wants to be somewhere else in
10 years just like you do so we're all
in the same boat and it's sometimes hard
to believe this no matter how rude they
might be no matter how you knows because
some of them are just there in those
kind of situations but my point is this
they're on your side because they have
to cast this thing and because people
are fundamentally lazy they'd rather be
home smoking pot and watching TV so
they want you to be good they want you
to solve their problem and too often I
think people don't realize that you have
to take the long view the short view is
I'm what this job I need this job in
with this job the long view is I have a
chance to meet someone I may admire
someone I could work with but I may not
be right for this job on this day that
has nothing to do with my talent it
could be a thousand reasons why you
don't get a job but if I'm good enough
if I stand on that stage and I show them
where my talent is on this day I walk
out that door they might look at each
other and go she's really good she's
really good she's not right for this but
she's really good and the next time they
do a film or the next time they do a
play they'll bring you back and some day
along that long road you may get that
job but it's about relationships and
it's about trusting yourself and where
you are and realizing you are good
enough for where you are right now on
that day and I believe in the long view
you don't have to compromise yourself
you know it's something you don't feel
good about then don't do it the most
important choices I made was to say no I
said you know many a time to two films
that I just did especially early on that
just didn't feel comfortable with a
it was one scoop that was brought to me
I call that the negative you couldn't
kill
like these Jews raising this wife
in the 40s and they try to hang on
everybody
so I actually called who I was fortunate
at that time to instill to be able to
call and I said you know this movie make
it I'm sick and they offered me six
hundred thousand dollars to play the
negative good
he said to me and I'll say this to you
he said the first two or three or four
films to make a decision to dental will
determine how to proceed
he said I'm not going to tell you what
to do but remember that the first three
or four or five things you making
determine on your receipt I turned it
down
I turned running down I need to turn it
down six months later I got try freedom
if you if you don't feel like I should
do it then don't do it because you don't
want to be you know you don't want to be
a negative energy on the set that's how
I feel so I'm like you know what I ain't
doing this does not even slap somebody
the second day
I think the most important decisions you
can make as an actor actress is saying
no they saying that we have to do
closed-off you don't do you remember the
audition when you first met an arrow
that was yeah I mean that was one of
those incredible auditions that came
around that I suppose every kid had been
waiting for for a long period of time
because it's just not that often that
you get a starring role above Robert De
Niro and this incredible you know the
screenplay and was you know Ellen Barkin
and Michael Keaton Jones I'm it was just
everyone was sort of feeding for this
role and I got done I suppose to the
final five and there was like a last
sort of day Toby was there and I I do
remember thinking to myself I got to do
something I got to do something to stand
out and in the audition those art
lengths and Michael Kate and Joan's art
lessons that was the producer and DeNiro
and I remember there was a mustard jar
scene and he had to jam a mustard jar in
my eye repeatedly it was an abuse scene
and the script so didn't call for it but
I got up and I he said now is it empty
is it empty and I got up and I screamed
Oh like completely unnecessary but I
screamed in his face and i sat there you
know with my head you know looking like
a red tomato and and and everyone
started laughing at me and then the
entire room de niro everybody was in
hysterics i sat there frozen's thinking
oh my god I just screwed this entire
and I just sat there frozen and then you
know Bob and traditional DeNiro fashion
kind of just looked at me went and and
then you know we carried on doing the
scene and I think I actually had dinner
with DeNiro recently and he told me no I
was the one who said I was the one who
said you should get the get the job you
know they clear your own personal blocks
right you have to be able to be
vulnerable in front of anybody you know
you have to be comfortable looking silly
you have to be comfortable making
mistakes and you have to break the thing
inside of you that doesn't want people
to see right because as soon as you will
allow people to see all of a sudden you
get access to things that you didn't
realize you that access to right for
example like a thing I used to do is
when I was in probably eighteen or
nineteen years old I got in touch with
those blocked the camera hates emotional
blocks like you put a camera in
somebody's face and they're
uncomfortable about deliver any emotion
it looks fake and you feel it you
immediately know it's not real right
especially look at the size of this
screen and give a shot that whole screen
could be just your eyes right so it's
like you can't hide discomfort
uncertainty so you have to be able to
get comfortable you know just
many have to be for the role you have to
be comfortable being
I was so scared but you know but that is
the part of it and there by the same
token you have to you'll be able to just
be be quiet to be nervous to really love
someone really at the end of the day
it's about finding ways like you have to
get comfortable doing it in front of
your father that block is the thing
you're going to apply to that maybe your
father is the popular to have for the
camera is the block you're gonna have
when there's a pretty girl behind the
camera that's working and you want to
look cool for her
you don't want her to see you cry you
know so think so that block you can use
your father if he make you uncomfortable
is perfect because that's the discomfort
you have to bring in order to be able to
bear yourself who's running the camera a
station is smart
no you said super Sparkle I got to say
smart stuff too so I have a story about
you actually so what you were saying I
feel like being afraid of girls being in
front of the camera being scared in
general all of those things are just
really the same thing it's just really
being afraid of what people will think
so I think why you can be such amazing
actors because when you were a teenager
in Philly
people go to the mall and he was up on
the chair like this he was saying hey
can I have your attention everybody
everybody my name is Will Smith and I'm
gonna be famous one day he was just
comfortable staying and doing anything
so we've got front of the camera you are
okay to let that emotion go you know
that was my practice for me to break
that fear yes sir those are great to
just have a party get comfortable
walking up saying hi and get rejected
hard copy online endeavor - got Africa
because acting and everything is
rejection that's what it is you do a
take and people don't clap it's
rejection and you can't allow that to
close you down because baring yourself
is what makes you look strong on camera
there's no point in doing something if
you're not gonna do it absolutely you
know and do it to the hill and and so
yeah they did come a point when I
suddenly started to get more
satisfaction out of it and realizing
there was something that even though I
can't quite bring myself to say
something of worth to it that I can say
something worth me doing it for and if
I'm gonna do it if I'm gonna take the
time to do it then I want to do it
in as much of an immersive way as
possible because you know you just come
to learn in life that the things that
you really get a kick out of are the
things that you just can't deny they're
the things that when you're doing them
you can think of nothing else but what
you're doing you know I [ __ ] up my
whole arm and wrist I've got metal
plates here and here and screws all up
and down my arm through
riding motorcycles not on the streets
but on racetracks and that was something
which I realized was was very much when
acting is good why I like it because
when you ride in a motorcycle to the
hilt knowing the danger involved you
have to be absolutely focused on what
you're doing you can't allow anything
else in and there is such a thrill to
doing that you know that's why it's so
hypnotic and just mesmerizing that I
just love it
and I realized that the best times I
feel a similar thing with acting and it
doesn't happen that often because it's a
team thing you know on a motorcycle it's
just you and it going this is a team
thing and you require the environment to
be created in which you can do that but
the when that does happen that's what I
love about it yeah well the best of the
best advice
fellow actors
know what your job is 18 years ago
cognition that I realized I was going
into auditions trying to get a job
and that simply wasn't what I was doing
it wasn't what I said both I'm supposed
to be
an actor is supposed to create a
compelling interest
that served the text we presented in
your audition
and then you walk away
everything else is out of your control
so don't even speak it don't focus on
that you're not going there to get a job
they're going there to present what you
do there it is and walk away when
there's power in that there's confidence
in them
there's also saying
I can only do so much and then the
decision of who might get a job is so
out of your control
it's been really when you analyze that
it makes no sense to hold on to that
that to me was a breakthrough and once I
adapted that philosophy
I never looked back and I've never been
busier in my life
and once I grab down to that I mean it's
important not to give yourself
boundaries which we can do quite easily
okay
people talk about aiming for the skies
sometimes even aiming for the skies is
intimidating just don't give yourself
boundaries your sky and my sky might be
different you know I mean but neither of
us have touched the sky if we give
ourselves boundaries you know I mean
whatever your sky is whatever your
biggest dream is I might have already
touched that you know so in other words
what sky where does the sky end I'd
rather people car you know what I'm not
gonna restrict myself to go I can only
do this so I can only do that oh I have
to do it this way all I have to do it
that way I think it's important that
people just go and lose the boundaries
lose the conformity and just go for it
I said look why why don't we change
everything up is the boost me be myself
just me Jackie Chan that takes a lot of
confidence yeah I believe also I really
thank you you know the producer would
see us he said okay do whatever you like
to do yeah change Nobu sleep harmony
when bootlicking hi I kick know what
when Bruce Lee after punch I used just
like normal human being
normal when I was young I'm fighting on
the street one by one
oh why knock somebody down to buy one
that somebody down three I'd run away so
in the movie do the same thing I just
everything used in the movie use me it's
my real life
I never imagined in my wildest dreams
that I would be successful
the fear is always bearing factors that
you'll never work again
oh how mean that goes with the territory
you have that fear the second the job
third job fourth job you have it all the
way down the line
so each happy event as it's happened has
been a surprise not out of the day then
I pick you flowers for a woman their
appreciation
I'm Damocles with the sword you know I
really think it's up there bias by a
hair and every day it doesn't happen I'm
just thrilled I never thought it was
going to happen to me you can't if
you're an actor
I'm really freaking here Johnny why is
he here some people do I guess go in
saying I'm gonna be a star and they are
but for all those people that say that I
bet there are hundreds of thousands we
say that and are still you know
struggling what you don't I don't know I
know a lot of my success has to do with
luck I've also poured a lot of hard work
into it so I feel in some way that I can
justify myself you know but I'm just
happy that I think respec happen this
way thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of the video do you want
this series to continue then you learn a
lot from it which part was your favorite
let me know in the comments what you
thought what'd you learn from it what
you're gonna apply to your life to your
business if we should continue this
series put it in the comments below and
I will join in the discussion I also
want to give a quick shout out to miss
Lin thank you so much for buying a copy
of my book it really really means a lot
to me so those are you watching if you
want your chance at a shout out in a
future video make sure to pick up a copy
of the book and email in your receipt so
you can keep track thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
where it is and I'll see you soon